cependant le dégel s'annonçait
sérieusement sur le front des grèves les
accords d'entreprise avait joué à la
ratp et les autobus sortait des dépôts
pour reprendre contact avec la chaussée
parisienne où on ne les avait pas vus
depuis longtemps les stations de métro
ou rouvraient leurs pas
on allait retrouver au matin le cortège
des écoliers alors que la reprise
restait limitée dans les lycées et
collèges
elle était quasi générale dans les
écoles primaires la situation était
moins clair du côté des grands magasins
parisiens où il s'avérerait que malgré
plusieurs tentatives les portes avec
quelques difficultés à s'ouvrir
mais c'est surtout dans l'industrie
automobile que la reprise paraissait
difficile
citroën avait demandé à son personnel de
se prononcer par un vote secret mais
l'occupation des usines continue et il
restait d'autres s'y réduit